today on the show the world's largest
porn site pornhub features literally
billions of hours of content has
hundreds of millions of users and a
sizable portion of that content is rape
and child porn and a sizable number of
those users are themselves very young
children now are there any laws in place
or any regulations penalizing pornhub
for this or forcing them to block
children from their from their site or
to weed out the rape and child porn not
really or at least if there are laws and
regulations they are not applied to
pornhub in any meaningful way
pornhub gets to be an exception to the
kinds of rules and policies and
regulations that are in place for for
instance things like liquor stores and
those sorts of companies now I don't
know I want to talk about this today I
just I have this crazy idea it's totally
radical but maybe pornhub shouldn't be
an exception maybe there should be some
really basic minimal at least
regulations that would that would
require pornhub to you know not actively
market themselves to kids that sort of
thing so what we'll talk about that
today
also five headlines including Biden's
big wins last night and also I think
more important or at least funnier Biden
nearly getting into a fistfight with a
voter right before right as right as
voting started and we're gonna talk
about that I have a take on Biden
threatening and cussing out voters that
might be a little bit different from
what you're gonna hear for most
conservative people in media and AOC
Alexandria Kaiser Cortes well I think
I've canceled her multiple times already
but she is the the the focal point of
today's daily cancellation because of a
video clip of her that I know you're
used to seeing her say all kinds of dumb
things but this this one really might
take the cake this this one it might
even surprise you a little bit that's
how dumb it is we're gonna play that for
you finally your emails including in our
why I'm wrong segments an email from
Jack who thinks that my show is terrible
and boring and I talk about unimportant
things that just don't matter at all I
need to find it but I need to find bear
better and more important things to talk
about he thinks maybe he's right we'll
find out today all of that coming up
first let's talk about zip recruiter you
know with minimum wage hikes all over
the country it's making it even more
important that employers find candidates
who are better than average because of
the more you got to pay them then that
means that they need to they need to
come with the with the skills that can
justify that salary according to the US
Bureau of Labor Statistics Hawaii is the
state experiencing the highest wage
growth but while higher wages attract
more and better candidates competition
for talent is very intense so if you
need to find the best candidates for
your growing business zip recruiter is
your smart efficient hiring solution
from healthcare to manufacturing to
professional business services whatever
it is zip recruiter makes hiring great
people faster and easier and today you
could try zip recruiter for free at zip
recruiter comm slash Walsh when you go
to zip recruiter with one click you send
your job it's a zipper Cooter's network
of over a hundred leading job sites what
happens next well zip recruiter finds
the best matches for your job invites
them to apply and it's so effective that
four out of five employers to post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day four out of five
the first day they get they get at least
one quality candidate so right now to
try zip recruiter for free my listeners
can go to zip recruiter comm slash wall
so that's zip recruiter comm slash Wal
SH zip recruiter comm slash Walsh zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire all
right so pornhub is facing renewed
criticism for for hosting thousands of
videos of sexual assault and child abuse
and there are so many cases of this that
we could talk about with pornhub in just
one case that that I think is especially
egregious 58 videos were uploaded of a
fifteen-year-old sex trafficking victim
being raped on camera there were 58
videos of her being raped on pornhub and
this is far from an isolated incident
there was another woman who recently
wrote a blog post talking about her own
experience of being raped at 14 and
eventually she found multi
videos of her assault on pornhub and the
videos
she says had titles like teen crying and
getting slapped around and passed out
teen one of them had close to half a
million views on the site now she
emailed she says she emailed pornhub
multiple times with increasing
desperation begging them pleading with
them to take this stuff down and they
just dig dig Nora no response totally
ignored her then she got an idea she
sent a message pretending to be a lawyer
and right away there was a response they
took the videos down these kinds of
stories again are common and inevitable
when you consider how pornhub operates
pornhub lets anybody upload hardcore
porn to their site now they claim they
take careful steps to weed out rape and
child porn that is clearly not the case
we know that is not the case we know
they're lying and it's not like the
content hangs out on the dimly lit
fringes of pornhub that's one of the
ways we know their line teen is one of
porn hubs most popular search terms and
they're proud of that you know every
year they release this infographic where
they talk about you know how many
billions of hours people spent watching
porn on their platform how many users
bragging about all the great success
they're having having they also will
openly tell you what the most common
search terms were and they tell you teen
is one of them and that they have no
problem with that at all
now of course companies that make
millions of dollars off of this stuff
once will insist that the rape videos
are only pretend rape and the the
thirteen-year-old girls in the teen
videos are really eighteen year olds
dressed up to look like high school
freshmen but we know for a fact that
that isn't the case even if it were the
case even if a word well then still I
would think that hopefully we could
agree there are some very serious
ethical problems with feeding the rape
and and
child abuse fantasies of would-be
pedophiles because if you go looking for
videos like that rape videos a video of
someone who looks 13 you can't say oh
it's just pretend first of all how do
you know you don't is the answer and
second of all why do you want to see
that even in pretend mode you're you're
one step away from a pedophile you you
obviously find that appealing I should
tell you something about yourself it
should tell something about about
pornhub that they happily cater to that
group yet this is only one facet of the
problem when it comes to pornhub and
sites like it the other issue is that
anybody at all of any age can visit
these domains and easily access billions
of hours of Filth and depravity stuff
that is so vile that was reading a story
recently about detectives police
detectives who have PTSD from having to
wade through a lot of this stuff in
order to find and prosecute child porn
and you know we need people to do that
so we can a pornhub is not doing it they
don't care but if we're going to
prosecute child porn which hopefully we
all agree they should that we need
people to go and find this stuff and
imagine what they have to sit and watch
to find it but our kids at 8 years old
can easily fall into that world too and
nothing stopping them whatsoever there
is no age verification conducted by
pornhub none they don't even pretend to
try now many gambling sites before
anyone says well what are they supposed
to do there's a lot they could do many
other sites do have age gambling sites
for example require many of them a
driver's license a passport a picture of
one to ensure that that people are of
age now there are there are more
stringent methods taken by some sites
where because of course you know you
could always grab your brothers
and take a picture of that well there
are other sites that say you need a
picture of the ID with it with with your
face right now you need to take a selfie
of yourself holding your ID things like
that now can that be manipulated yes it
can but it's it's it's something many
people are gonna find a way around that
many other people won't though so you
are going to keep a lot of people out
who otherwise you would not have kept
out crypto currency exchanges use use
similar measures stock trading sites
even sites now I know this as someone
who I am as a bourbon fan you know I
like to go and look at reviews of new
Bourbons that I'm gonna try and if I go
to a bourbon review site inevitably
there's gonna be a prompt that comes up
and says are you over the age of 21 and
if you say no it kicks you right out of
the site and that's just to read about
alcohol okay to read about alcohol
requires age verification obviously
easily circumvent that I could just say
yes I'm over 21 when I'm not but the
point is pornhub doesn't even do that
much they don't even do that they do
less than what a bourbon review site
does they make absolutely no effort
whatsoever to keep kids away from
hardcore rape porn on their site and
that should concern all of us in a
country where eight-year-olds on average
are being exposed to porn in fact the
situation is worse than pornhub simply
making no effort to protect kids on the
contrary they market themselves to
underage kids I want to show you this
take a look at this this was anything
what an Instagram post of theirs
recently and talking about you know
referencing people going on pornhub
after their parents leave well who do
you who do you think this is targeted to
you got yeah baby Yoda they're talking
about going to look at porn when your
parents leave the house who do you think
this is a this is a marketing tool
advertising who are they advertising to
do you think they're advertising to 19
year olds are the average the
advertising to
two thirty-five year old men who live
with their parents I mean I fully
believe that people in that camp watch a
lot of porn but you think that's through
their primarily targeting there no
unless you're very stupid unless you're
willingly stupid you know they are
marketing that that is advertisement to
underage kids and they're allowed to do
it do you think a cigarette company
could get away with that anymore not
even close do you think of an alcohol
company could get away with that now you
might say that they find other ways of
marketing the kids and I'm sure they do
but they can't be that explicit about it
I mean imagine that exact advertisement
except from Budweiser and it's a picture
of baby Yoda drinking a beer right after
my parents leave the house and he's
drinking a beer do you think you think
they could you think that would ever
happen I mean they'd be sued to kingdom
come
if they put a an ad like that out
pornhub can do it the port hubs an
exception why are they an exception
nobody can explain why they just are
they get to be an exception only a
nation of impotent cowards and
emasculated narcissists who care more
about protecting their sacred
masturbation material than they do about
protecting kids would sit back and allow
smut peddlers in this kind of free reign
as if they have some sort of god-given
natural right to show gangbang videos to
third graders the good news is we don't
have to allow it and you don't have to
agree with my previously stated views on
banning porn to agree because I'm
putting that aside okay let's try to and
I know that I'm very much in the
minority with that view doesn't mean I'm
wrong
I don't care about being in the minority
I find that oftentimes I find it's it's
it's more likely that if you find
yourself in the majority in this culture
on an issue it's more likely you're
wrong on that but
put that aside doesn't matter we're not
talking about that you don't have to
agree with me on that but that
completely to the side you should still
be able to agree that sites like pornhub
should at least be subject to minimal
regulations to prevent them from
profiting off of the abuse and
corruption exploitation of children now
few of us with the exception of
absolutist libertarians with the
exception of the kind of people who
still think that Atlas Shrugged was it
was a literary masterpiece with the
exception of those people few of us
would argue that it's some sort of
tyranny or oppression to require liquor
stores to verify the age of their
customers does anybody really get upset
about that do you feel like your
freedoms are under assault when you go
in to buy a beer and the person I guess
it says can I see an ID you said my
freedoms my freedoms I'm not free
wouldn't you haven't no nobody says that
you just show your ID it's not a big
deal and even though we think parents
should be trying to stop their kids from
binge drinking we would all agree we
agree on that this is a this is a
parenting thing primarily the first line
of defense when stopping a kid from
becoming a binge drinker is the parents
but even so companies that sell alcohol
should bear some responsibility if an
eight-year-old walks into the Kwik Stop
and comes out with 40 ounces of malt
liquor in his hand you know you could
say that he mean that means he has bad
parents fine that doesn't justify the
neglect of the person behind the counter
who chose to sell that product to
someone who is clearly underage and made
no attempt whatsoever to verify the age
so bad parents doesn't justify that
maybe he does it okay he has bad parents
okay fine he has bad parents yes so what
do we say to the kids
screw you we're did nothing well you're
out of luck kid no protection whatsoever
if you have bad parents you have no
protection we're doing nothing for you
is that the message we sent as a society
no and nobody actually thinks that
should be the
which is why we all agree unless we're
insane we all agree that a someone at ab
liquor store who sells liquor to an
eight-year-old should be prosecuted as
previously stated we even expect other
kinds of websites to do this and nobody
has a problem with it
I don't see anyone complaining that it's
it's a dystopia we're living in because
you have to verify your age to go on a
stock trading site
why should pornhub be an exception what
makes them special other than the fact
that a lot of people like porn as has
been proposed in other countries like
Australia for example a law could and
should be passed requiring sites like
pornhub to make some attempt to verify a
user's age we all understand that no age
verification system will be perfect they
can be circumvented circumvented but any
system is a hell of a lot better than no
system especially if that system
requires a photo ID a credit card
something like that alternatively as has
also been proposed adults who wish to
access porn could be required to opt in
with their Internet service provider you
put all the porn on a dot XX domain you
got to call your net service provider
you opt in and that that would take the
the privacy concerns out Union you might
say well I don't want to give my ID in
my credit card to a porn company I don't
have a lot of sympathy for that if you
really want if you really want that that
that content then I mean if you're gonna
support a site like pornhub that makes
millions of dollars on child porn which
is what they do and they do it on
purpose if you're gonna support them
then then you know honestly you the fact
that you'll be inconvenienced or have to
worry about identity theft I don't
really care about that but we don't even
need to do that there are other ways
opt-in I mean there are a lot of debt
I've just mentioned a couple of
different ways but there are other ways
too if we as a society decided this was
a priority this is something we wanted
to do we could easily do it
and in order to cut back on the rape and
child porn on the platform pornhub could
be required by law to block search terms
that are directly related to that kind
of content and don't give me the free
speech thing it's not free speech to go
online and pursue rape videos that's not
free speech you should not be able to
upload a video titled passed-out team
and you shouldn't be able to search for
a video like that sex with a passed-out
teen is rape it would be very easy very
easy for pornhub to filter out videos
that explicitly advertise themselves as
rape videos it's right there in the
title saying hey this is a rape video
pornhub could easily find that stuff and
get rid of it they don't because they
have no interest in because they'd
rather make the money on it because
they're degenerate filthy scumbags
running that site and they don't do it
because the law doesn't require them to
do it I'm not advocating for a big
brother dystopia I'm not saying the
government should parent my kids I'm not
trying to legislate morality so maybe we
could put all of those dumb cliched
slogans to the side I'm talking about
basic reasonable not terribly onerous
measures that would put sites like
pornhub right in line with other
companies that sell products we have
deemed unsuitable for children
sure and and and I know that and before
you give me the saw reasonable
regulations that sounds like the kind of
thing that people who support gun
control advocate for yes except that gun
control is a right guaranteed and in the
Second Amendment
hardcore rape porn is not a right
guaranteed but more to the point yes a
common-sense regulation like for
instance that a gun you know someone
selling guns should have - you can't
sell a handgun to a child that is a
common-sense regulation I agree with I
hope we all do of course so how about
let's just get to that point with
pornhub my point is they don't even have
to do that all of these other companies
that provide products that we all agree
children should not have access to all
of them have to do things very basic
things they don't have to go way above
and beyond it's not like a liquor store
has to call every time someone comes in
they gotta they gotta you know call a
reference or check your resume just a
basic thing you have to do doesn't stop
all the underage kids it does stop some
of them and maybe some you know those of
us who have been underage as we all have
been maybe we there were certainly times
and we were able to circumvent those
procedures at liquor stores there were
other times when we weren't able to so
it did work sometimes at least pornhub
doesn't have to do anything why should
they be the only ones why should the
porn industry be the only industry that
is not required to take any measures
whatsoever to keep kids away from their
product that is not suitable for them
doesn't make any sense yes I would
prefer to burn the porn industry to the
ground and salt the earth with his with
its ashes that's what I would prefer to
do so guilty as charged but I don't
think you need to hold that position you
don't need to agree with me on that to
see that pornhub is harming kids and
monetizing that harm and they're doing
it on purpose and they have no right to
do it and we could take steps to at
least put obstacles and barriers in the
way and get it get get get a handle on
some of the problem we could take those
steps there is no good reason not to
time is running out to get 25% off great
another great segue by me time is
running out to get 25% off all daily
wired membership plans using coupon code
never socialist this is the last week
we're giving you for this offer and it's
you know you don't want to miss out this
is you get one more week we keep
extending it being being far my opinion
far too generous I don't think we should
be this nice but we are and you get that
you get that discount of membership
because
and you don't want to miss out on a
daily wire members get an ad-free
website experienced access to all of our
live broadcasts show library including
the mat wall show full three hours of
ben shapiro show access to the mailbag
and now exclusive election insight
op-eds from ben shapiro as well so
you're getting that written content on
top of everything else
daily wire members also get to ask us
questions live like many of you saw
during the super tuesday backstage along
with all this of course you get the
magnificent the irreplaceable the the
gorgeous the beautiful the all inspiring
and inspirational sacred and mystical
leftist tears tumblr and if you haven't
already download the daily water apps
you can get all of our great content on
the go again that's 25% off the daily
wire our memberships for all plans using
coupon code never socialist so head on
over to daily wire calm / subscribe the
deal is ending this week so join now
that's daily wire calm / subscribe ok
it's a headlines number one many many
many Super Tuesday I guess I don't
that's what we're calling it but it
happened yesterday Joe Biden took a
commanding lead in the delegate count he
won four more states including Michigan
which is a state that Bernie Sanders won
in 2016 not this time so this is being
being hailed or more depending on where
you're coming from it as the death knell
of Bernie's campaign Biden now has eight
hundred and thirty seven delegates which
puts him almost halfway to what he needs
for the nomination don't check my math
on that you need 1990-91 for the
nomination so he's got 837 Brian
Williams says that means he needs 46
million more delegates I'm not really
sure but it isn't over for Bernie
Sanders don't be too upset he may have
gotten routed last night and on Super
Tuesday he may be losing states he won
in 2016 he may not get the nomination
but he'll be back in 2024 at the age of
83 I think we all know that they'll
wheel him in there and then he's 87
he'll be back again as long as he is
physically able to say one word
billionaire or - maybe - billionaire bad
if he could say those two words if he
can somehow get those words out or even
just do it through sign language that
his
campaign will live on because that is
his entire campaign that's it that's all
he's got number two speaking of Michigan
this also happened in Michigan Joe Biden
yesterday got into a heated exchange
with a voter about his policies on guns
and it's a sight to behold look look at
this
[Music]
that's the forty-second fire
that's not Scrooge speak
my sons would guess what now I know
anyway I'm not taking a gun away
at all I did not say that that's what I
try to get not share that video with a
viral then they're like the other ones
you put down to do the whole boys
so he says it might be a little bit hard
to hear there but he says you're full of
s to the guy don't try me pal you want
to go outside he really says that don't
be a horse's ass and this is all because
the the voter is asking him some very
good basic reasonable questions about
his gun control policies now I know this
puts me outside the general conservative
consensus on this as I am with most
things but I maintain I insist that Joe
Biden is never more relatable or
likeable then when he's getting in
shouting matches with random people and
cussing them out that's the only time I
like Joe Biden is in those moe these are
the things upset people the most
especially conservatives conservatives
are going nuts about this online
yesterday I just absolutely nuts really
upset and angry but I'm thinking this is
the only thing about him I like maybe
I'm crazy or maybe this is how I argue
with my friend when we get into a debate
about something it pretty much always
goes there eventually somebody's
threatening to punch somebody it might
also be an Irish thing I think Biden is
is of Irish descent I'm not sure about
that but he acts like it sometimes and
so it might be an Irish thing to you it
just you know there's think there's a
lot of passion that comes out in an
argument violent threats are made rarely
followed up on it's just it's part of
the leg it's how we speak now what I'll
say is whether you agree with me on that
or not I think this is much more
preferable to you know I would prefer
this this hey you're being a horse's ass
shut up you want to take this outside
pal why I'll give you a knuckle sandwich
of course the other great thing is that
as always he makes threats as if he's
Dick Tracy or something as if he's in a
you know 1950s detective
but I'd prefer that over what you
normally get from candidates which is
when they're talking to the middle class
and blue-collar voters it's the middle
class is the backbone of America they're
perfect in every way I love you in the
middle class you're so great I wish I
was in the middle class there's nothing
better than the middle class all of you
are so awesome come here middle class
let me give you a kiss and hug come here
III paraphrasing what almost every
candidate says to the middle class as a
member of the middle class myself I'm
not into that I'm not into it on several
different levels I don't need that I
don't need you sucking up to me I don't
need you to pretend that being middle
class is the is the ultimate dream it's
the it's the goal of it no nobody you
are all in the middle class just by
default nobody gets to middle class and
says yeah this is all I want I'm good
here or I think very few people do and
even the people who are content which I
think contentment is good but it's it's
not like their goal was to be middle
class right so I don't need that I would
much prefer Biden's approach at least
it's authentic and it's also hilarious
so I'm not clutching my pearls over this
number three in coronavirus news reading
from a report in the LA Times it says an
analysis of the novel coronavirus is
spread inside the United States suggest
that thousands of Americans are already
infected dimming the prospects of or
stopping out the outbreak in its
earliest stages researchers estimate
that by March 1st the virus had already
infected about 1,000 to 10,000 people
have not yet been accounted for released
into a country of about 330 million each
of these it talks about the small group
of travelers who came here with
coronavirus and it says each of these
travelers was assumed to have passed the
virus to two to two-and-a-half people
each of whom in turn infected another
two to two-and-a-half and so on and so
on
towed up the nodes on this rapidly
branching network of contacts and the
numbers of victims balloons quickly the
researchers wrote of course it makes
sense that there are way more cases than
being reported and on the positive end
of that as we've discussed it probably
means the mortality
rate is much lower than what they are
reporting but I do wonder about the
logic here of assuming that each person
passes it to two people on and on and on
because that doesn't seem to account for
a change in behavior we aren't these
estimates not taking into account the
increased awareness and even paranoia
over the disease that might change
people's behavior and stop them from
passing it on to the requisite to people
I don't know it just it seems like you
have to account for that number for also
on the subject of the coronavirus people
are finding novel ways to protect
themselves from the virus as this local
news report shows don't nobody want
thanks Adebisi and don't nobody want to
take that matters today house parents
with children at Treadwell middle and
elementary schools are not playing
around
many wipe their kids down and some even
sprayed them with disinfectant spray as
they took them home Monday and I'll wipe
my shoes and backpack down when I got
him out of school shooter you gave them
closure these parents are doing this
after they found out an employee who
works at Treadwell middle and elementary
came in contact with a person who tested
positive for the corona virus in Memphis
some took more extreme measures to know
sex while the SES employee is
quarantined the district is focusing on
making sure everything is clean still
family members tell me they don't want
their kids in school no folks examine
your phone you know I have to say I
don't feel too protected by this it just
doesn't
III feel maybe I need to spray Lysol
directly in my face as well like the
like the dad was doing to his son which
doesn't seem too healthy but this right
here I guess it's better than nothing
but I feel like there are a lot of
access points still for the corona virus
to get in here number five the headline
in the New York Post I'll just give you
the headline in the New York Post this
is all I'm giving you headline is
coronavirus conference canceled in New
York because of corona virus and I was
going to go on and explain what this
story is about but I think we just leave
it there they cancelled the coronavirus
conference because they realized that
the corona virus exists one of the
corona virus conference
I said to the other one hey have you
heard about this thing called the corona
virus it's pretty contagious the other
one said Corona and I hadn't heard about
that well I guess we should cancel the
corona virus conference and that's how
that ended up having but pretty smart
decision all right now let's go to your
dear I'm not gonna I'm not gonna I
thought about wearing the bag for the
entire show but I'm not gonna do that
not safe either
don't try that at home kids don't put
bags over your head much much much
greater likelihood of suffocating on a
bag over your head than dying of
coronavirus I think we probably agree
now this feels like almost like cheating
honestly but I'm pretty sure I've
canceled her already probably multiple
times but today we're canceling aoc
again because of this honestly it sounds
almost so silly to say but there's a lot
of restaurants that are feeling the pain
of racism where people are literally not
patronage Chinese restaurants they're
not patron occasion restaurants because
of just straight-up racism around the
coronavirus okay so a few a few problems
here just just a few she made about five
error errors five significant errors in
twenty seconds that's one about one
every five seconds which is consistent
with her overall average first Chinese
is not a race I want everyone to get
that up through their heads all of the
race-baiting leftist who are trying to
get it find racism in the coronavirus
thing Chinese is not a race you can't be
racist against Chinese people there are
many different ethnicities in China and
to lump them all together
well if anything that's racist if
anything second pay training is not a
word the word you're searching for
Alexandre is patronizing and I don't
mean to be patronizing when I tell you
this but patronizing patronage would be
spelled patr o ni ng which would be
pronounced patronum and it would involve
I suppose dumping Patron tequila over
somebody's head
that's a Patroni when you've done that
you've patron someone
third you can't be racist against a
restaurant or a type of food if people
are worried even irrationally worried
that there might be a disease in a
particular restaurant it's not racist to
avoid that restaurant and even leaving
aside the fact that China is in a race
restaurants aren't a race either and
neither is a food food doesn't have race
so it's not bigoted to avoid a place
where you think you might be exposed to
a disease forth people are avoiding
restaurants in general so it's this is
this is not anything unique if I decided
not to go to Olive Garden tonight is
that bigoted against Italian people
is this an attack on Italians no if
anything it's an attack on Italians to
go to Olive Garden and fifth point
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez is an enormous
ly stupid individual and six
she's canceled again until next week it
will cancel her once again well just do
it it will do it a weakly she'll be a
weekly feature okay let's go to emails
and you can email the show you can
access the mailbag by becoming a member
become a daily wired member as we've
just discussed this is from Matthews
says hi Matt I really enjoyed your new
book as a recently married Catholic I
found it to be a fountain for
conversation with my new wife I've never
read a faith book that wasn't written by
CS Lewis so thank you for writing
something that's compelling challenging
and humorous keep up the good work
fighting for Catholicism culture and
conservatism you give me positive
support daily in your podcast and we
keep you and your family in our prayers
thank you for that it's unfortunate that
you had to have the same name as me
because now it's gonna sound like I
wrote that complimentary email to myself
and yes I would be dumb enough to write
a fake email to myself with my own name
from anonymous when you first started
this porn crusade I thought you were
crazy but the more you talked about it
the more I began to think for myself I'm
trying to quit porn now and because you
I because of you I made the decision to
research and come to the conclusion it
wasn't healthy for me you're doing a
good thing don't let people tell you
otherwise not that you would haha well
the fact that you thought I was crazy
but you listened to anyway it actually
gave my arguments consideration I'm
grateful for that I wish more people
would do it not just with me but in
general you hear something you think
it's crazy
let me hear it out let me be at least
listen to the argument maybe it is crazy
but let me at least listen to the fact
that you did that is great
now this email segment had been way too
warm and cozy and agreeable so far so
let's stop with the kumbaya stuff and
let's get to why I'm wrong this is a why
I'm wrong email of sorts not really
taking issue with my arguments as far as
I can tell but more with my topic
selection my general approach my
everything about me but it's it's more
it's more about me as a person that it
is about my organs okay this is from
Jack says we get it you don't like porn
though I think you protest a little too
much and you don't like drag queens and
you don't like abortion if you're
wondering why your show isn't as popular
as the others
maybe it's because you go on and on
about this bull s nobody cares about how
many times are you going to rant and
rave about porn there are so many issues
in the world and this is what you decide
to go on about if you don't like porn
don't watch it all caps if you don't you
don't need to go on a holy crusade over
it if you don't care about I know you
don't care about my opinion you don't
care about anyone's opinion but maybe
you should consider other people's
perspective besides your own for a
change
nobody wants to hear you talk about porn
every day or drag queens or see your
articles about it every day give it a
rest and find something else to talk
about
and then maybe people will care about
your show just a thought and by the way
I'm a conservative telling you this Jack
thank you for the email I want to stop
and think about this for a second
how many shows have I done that's not a
rhetorical question I really don't know
the answer I think it's four hundred
something maybe 450 450 I think about
there how many articles have I written
total since I started doing this I mean
going back to before the daily water
I assume this email that you wrote was
about my article on porno that I wrote
yesterday because obviously you sent it
before I did my show about it
but and you should know by now that the
best way to get me to do a show on a
topic is to send me an email telling me
to stop doing shows on that topic but so
how many articles I don't know how many
articles I've written in like in my life
ever since I had a platform and I was
and I've been in this position whatever
that position is so I don't know maybe
3,000 articles that's a conservative
estimate roughly let's just call it that
let's call 3,000 so 450 shows 3,000
articles give or take between these two
mediums how many of them do you think
were about porn or not even about porn I
mean how many and how many of those did
I even mention porn I could tell you
it's not 3,000 and 450 not anywhere even
close to that I'd say I've maybe done
five or six shows about porn out of 450
maybe and you could check me on that
maybe five or six total on the subject
and I've written maybe ten articles
about it total we could even call it 20
it's not 20 but we could call it that
so out of thousands of articles 20 have
been about porn out of hundreds of shows
five or six have been about porn so talk
about it every day not even close not
even in the vicinity or the ball not
even in the vicinity of the ballpark of
close I don't come anywhere close to
talking about it every day
so it's not that you're upset that I
talk about it every day you're upset and
be honest about this you're upset that I
talk about it at all not every day at
all you don't want to hear about it at
all you cannot tolerate any discussion
of the dangers of porn or its effect on
people and kids especially
you don't want any time devoted to it at
all and I know that because I devote
very little time to it probably a lot
less than I should and it's too much for
you in fact it's so much that it seems
to you like I talk about it every day
well it's not even close to that so what
does that say about you which one of us
has the issue here which one of us has
an unhealthy fixation is it the guy
who's produced hundreds of hours of
content and thousands of pages of
articles and dedicated a small fraction
of them to the porn problem or is it the
guy who can't even stomach that small
fraction which one of us do you think as
for the gender stuff the drag queens
abortion sorry I certainly talk about
those especially abortion far more often
why well because 60 million babies have
been killed by abortion since roe v--
wade i tend to think that's pretty
important in fact I can't think of an
issue that's more important than 60
million babies dead as for the gender
stuff drag queens and everything why do
I talk about that because it represents
the sexual exploitation of children the
corruption of children it's an assault
on reality and common sense and science
and decency and I consider that to be
rather important - let me ask you this
and I'm picking on you a little bit only
because you're sort of an avatar right
right now for me of the many people who
write to me or leave comments or send
messages on and on and have done so over
the years telling me exactly what you're
telling me so I know that you're not
alone there are others that feel the
same way you talk about this stuff too
much well let me ask you or anyone who
feels this way what would you have me
talk about instead everyday take out all
the time I've spent on these topics and
replace it with what exactly what issues
are more important what issues are more
important to you in your mind and are
not talked about enough already
politics you want me to get on here
every day and say blah blah Dems are bad
Joe the Trump is under attack blah blah
let's do another show on the attack on
Trump the media doesn't like Trump Chomp
Chomp Chomp
how something tells me if I did that
every day if I was like other
conservative media people fortunately
none here at the Daily wire because I
really do love the other shows and I
think there's a wide you know the other
guys are thoughtful and interesting and
I think we provide a pretty diverse
array of ideas and approaches and
perspectives and everything but there
are plenty of conservative media people
who every single day all they do all
they ever do is talk Trump in politics
Trump and politics Trump in politics
would that be better something tells me
if I did that you wouldn't be
complaining in fact I can't help but
notice that people on Twitter someone
some of them who say this stuff to me
that you say that I talk about porn
every day or whatever drag queens
abortion even though I don't some of
those same people every day they retweet
and share the same dull tired redundant
political talking points the Dems hate
America they hate America the media is
bad which they do of course they do hate
America and the media is bad and I've
said that too and I talk about that but
you want me to say that every day do you
need that every single day the same
thing over and over and over get is that
the content you want here's why this
annoys me and it's got nothing to do
with wanting you to like my show because
you're right I don't care if you do or
not but it annoys me because leaving my
content out of it so many conservatives
still do not understand that there are
deeper issues than politics that
politics is further up the tree it's not
at the root if you're talking politics
and I'm not saying we should never talk
politics but when you do that you're
chopping away at twigs and branches you
are not at the root the issues
pertaining to life marriage gender
family children even pop culture and yes
pornography these issues are far more
important they have a far greater effect
on people on culture on society in our
trajectory and future as a civilization
they just do these issues I talk about I
mean maybe you've noticed I've been
alive for 33 years we've had Republican
presidents Democrat presidents it hasn't
really made that much of a difference
our we are we still are marching along
the same trajectory going on the same
path look as a culture it hasn't really
mattered that much the issues that I
talked about that you've decided you
don't want to hear about the issues that
I'm
- obsessed about in your mind they're
way more important than whatever else
you think I should be harping on if you
can't see that if you don't understand
that if you still don't see that after
all this time and after all this
evidence you are part of the reason why
the left has won the culture and
conservatives are left scavenging for
crumbs and talking about political BS
you're part of the reason why the left
has won the culture so convincingly so
completely that I say we should put some
basic regulations on the porn industry
to stop them from marketing to children
and so-called conservatives join the
left in resisting that it's astounding I
mean they beat you jack you join them
they beat you they own you you are their
Lackey they have you when you're sitting
there saying dad let's not attack the
porn industry I don't care about
abortion you are theirs and I don't care
how much you talk about sharp or how
much you like Trump you are theirs they
own you they beat you here's the
interesting thing I want you to think
about in closing all the people who tell
me the issues I talked about don't
matter and aren't important you know who
those people are
they're never leftist I get a lot of
blowback from leftist as you might
expect and why do you think I get so
much by the way do you think these media
people who only ever talk about Trump do
you think they get a fraction of what I
get they don't I can tell you that right
now
they don't why is that well the left is
when they send me their hate mail and I
can show you the receipts they don't
tell me stop talking about abortion it
doesn't matter they don't tell me stop
talking about porn it doesn't matter
they don't even tell me that the drag
queens in and then you know the trans
stuff and the gender they don't say it
doesn't matter no the exact opposite
yeah they say well I read to you some of
the stuff they said about me when I
you're a you're a threat to the lives of
LGBT people your your this is this is a
danger to blood with you that's the way
they go they don't say it doesn't matter
the own
people who are dumb enough to say it
doesn't matter are the Conservatives and
that's why we lose and have lost because
we're the only ones dumb enough to think
that issues that pertain to life and
family and kids don't matter we're the
only ones stupid enough to say that and
it's just stupid Ethan I'm tired I I
can't stomach it you wanna talk about
not being able to stomach things I can't
stomach that anymore we gotta wake the
hell up because because we're losing and
we're gonna continue to lose unless we
realize come to the realization that
this stuff really does matter and and
the fact that our kids are watching porn
at the age of eight it really really
matters and and 40 years from now thirty
years from now when we've got a
generation of adults who have been
raised on hardcore porn since before
they hit puberty
I mean we're gonna see how much it
matters and by then it's gonna be too
late and
you're gonna be complaining about about
about what's happened to the culture and
where we are yet you were part of the
problem because when we could have done
something we could have talked about it
you didn't want to hear about it thanks
for the email and thanks everybody for
watching Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 Joe Biden ended Bernie Sanders's
campaign last night with massive
victories in Missouri Mississippi and
Michigan we will examine how Bernie fell
apart and what troubles lay ahead for
sleepy Joe then eat the rich YouTube
socialist Carlos masa gets exposed as a
rich guy revealing a key generational
difference between old left socialists
like Sanders and millennial socialists
like maza all that and so much more
check it out on the Michael Noel's show